how you doing guys this is
20 and I'm Lester green this is our
triptych conversation
phone courage
what is something that most filmmaking
that all is hey what's that word that
starts with a F hmm what is it
funding yes funding there the word that
a lot of filmmakers a lot of artists
don't like that word yeah we don't have
it basically yeah we don't have it yeah
but we want to talk about how to get
that funding I see a lot of videos talk
about funding and how to raise money to
me it's a lot of noise it's not real I
don't feel right I don't feel like is
authentic
you have story tell us I have a couple
stories yeah money story okay so I
created a film I'm not gonna mention the
name of it and I produced it of course
and I had somebody else who was gonna
help me produce the project what ended
up happening is that person for whatever
reason couldn't deliver looks like going
on a date right yeah was a shitty bill
you get that big bill right you only
want yeah so I had to pick up a tab and
I covered everything and of course the
film got completed and we submitted to
festivals and now we're winning a lot of
wars getting into a lot of festivals and
now it feels like everybody is coming
back on the back on the bandwagon
exactly and this is all about building
the brand so when you first start let's
be honest no one kids no kids much the
idea when I first started this industry
I had so many great ideas but no one
cared so I said how do I make people
care
I don't have the money get the big-name
I didn't really have oh yeah I have
money but I have a lot of money right so
I decided you know what let me know let
me stop waiting for someone to tell me
validate no one validate myself so I had
no kids
I worked my 9 to 5 save up money and I
decided to invest in myself I took a
little time we have to invest in
yourself people invest in you so once I
invest in myself guess what happened
people want to come on my bus now well
you know what it's nothing wrong with
that you have to realize that
it's your vision you can't get mad if
someone else to your vision that's why
you gotta build your brand and the more
you build your brand the more you do for
yourself the more people invest in you
yes be honest you know the time we
living in now and not everybody have a
lot of money to spend but they feel like
they're you know what this kid is doing
a lot this clinic is doing a lot
this female doing a lot it's a safe
investment could they fight they're
gonna get their money back
they're gonna be a better investment
just about building your brand so if you
were active you know let's the green
that angle so tell me Lester how do you
get to be often now a war winning actor
a war wood and producer how did this
happen I know how happened well no well
Antoine Allen was the main sparkplug
behind getting me off my feet so I gave
him all the credit for that but I will
say this though I think with me and this
helps if you have a really good day job
it doesn't have to be a day job you can
hear a good job you didn't they're right
if you have a good job it's consistent
and you make a decent salary then you
can actually put up some of your own
money to create your projects that's
what I was doing I put up most of the
money from my own pocket so yes that's
just so basically as a filmmaker as a
director producer writer acted less
there's an amazing talent amazing actor
but towels are nothing more you need
wanted talent so I was spent less than
my films but Melissa decided to be
partnership Wow
partnership not just a word but to
action you put up money I'll put up
money he put up money I put on my shoe
and now we got films on TV we got some
networks meetings we don't film courage
now with our own web series and it's
really it's like a bank account lot put
a hundred you put a hundred if I'm
putting so much money in and all you
doing is withdrawing it's not a
partnership definitely not so first step
of building your brand is fine other
people to help you build your brand with
so you got to have something me know
Lester you know we've had money to get
it doodle projects find the right
partner that's the first thing another
thing don't chase money attract money a
lot of people spend so much time can I
have some money could I have some money
help me
I want to know what have you put it mmm
I don't want to hear how many trips you
have how many ideas you have I don't
want to know throw me something where
have you been doing for yourself right
because if I come into picture and you
want me to invest so much money in you
we'll have you done for yourself so to
build your work building a wharf is
basically putting in that work
show me your resume show me something
you know only get yourself
yeah investing yourselves as filmmakers
as all this period when I meet them they
want me and best to work with them you
got to have a portfolio nothing crazy
please have a website right I don't want
your Instagram backslash don't want your
Facebook backslash you know I think I'll
somewhere our filmmakers we do the bare
minimal and we expect so much so
building it work number three start
doing things that attract people to
invest in you we just had a premiere for
I did a film showcase and I showed my
recent projects and I for my opinion if
you gotta pay to get in there I was a
ticket when I see filmmakers do free
screenings it's cool at first mmm baffle
Wow
you got to put money on top of your
product that's when you found out your
real fans easy to a feel a free event
everybody gonna come good point you put
the money on it you get to find a whole
voice you really do for you that's good
if your mama your daddy baby don't
really support it and just the reality
of it you know just podcast series is a
eye-opener different perspective real
conversations arrange a reality check
so whistling without the phone so with
number three number three so number one
bill your brand right number two I'll
probably mixing in order know your work
and number three get the right partners
around to help you build your brand I
have an amazing team and we accomplish
so so so so much
right so watching this video this series
when you go on film courage and you own
a YouTube channel look for our trip to
conversations please cuz you're gonna
get some real talk real stories let me
tell you this story when I first started
I needed money for my feature in my
future my first feature life too short
it cost me $25 to do I acts like here to
help me I didn't get a lot of help and I
take it personally because once again
it's my vision
I can't speck someone else to believe in
my adventures my vision and also to
prove me to see things first sometimes
you know we have all the great ideas but
they don't want to invest in you I get
it
so mojo the money I invested into it and
then from there my next feature I'm not
even barely paying for it I got other
messes painful for me did not exceed
what I'm doing another part about
building your brain is social media you
know sometimes I got a lot of filmmakers
and all this come to me for investment
and what I do is I go to your social
media they simply don't see me done for
yourself you know be careful to post
online if the last 15 posts was about
how you hate this person how you fill in
stuff like that it makes me wonder shy
invest you now some people might say hey
it's my personal page actually it's not
because you were you weren't asking for
a regular job I worked in a job before
we kind of look at social media to
determine it was gonna hire or not to be
very careful when you post online yeah
and yeah investing yourself man like
this is nothing more beautiful than
looking at that idea that no one
believed in and Transat success story so
on let's agree the actor yeah let the
people know that you know I saw
something less of that he didn't see
himself oh yeah let the people know that
hi Phil from one in your party life all
you was really doing is going to cast in
the record I don't want auditions and
open to get that leading role yeah but
now you know thanks to our teamwork you
in a position of power so speaker to get
actors feel acting but to know about
that definitely I got in my book I have
a I talk about this just having your own
power creating your own power and I
recently produced a film called I got a
call back and it feels so good to see my
name Lester green presents I got a call
back and it's nice to see it on the big
screen at festivals winning awards
getting nominated and it's just it's a
great feeling and I never saw any of
this happening I always told myself it's
just an actor I never saw myself as a
producer at some point I probably want
to do some
directing I want to try a little of
everything but it starts there once you
start to see that you can do it then you
want to do more of it and you want to
kind of branch out and do other things
so it's a good feeling I love it and I
don't want to stop yeah and then as an
active man like like I see your talents
are enough as actually you have to build
your brain don't think because you are
active you don't have to blow your brain
I know the business side is not sexy at
all yeah but you have to do it you know
yeah you have the kids on Instagram
that's getting TV shows and they never
step in the audition room in their life
they figure out they built they burn
talk about that I built the branch of
the roles that you've been fighting for
for the last 20 years the kidnapping on
Instagram for six months with over
happening it follows he just took every
road that you want why because they
understand building a brand you know
back in the day it was none of this it
was per Italian yeah but now there's
this tricks it's like a magic show so
why Wes yeah anything is possible
anything goes anything goes yeah a lot
of my success is not because I'm just
amazing filmmaker it's the business side
of me the market is a branded and even
if you don't know nobody mmm or even you
don't possess that silly get someone I
write you write you know with Lester his
stories are great because how does it
feel now you don't really have to go to
a casting director yeah just are you
know and also be the minority
you know Latino the black community
justice being a minded group it's a lot
of roles for us out there
so now we could create our own roles you
don't have to move the Hollywood we
could be out on Hollywood no matter who
you are what that's now you are your
powers in your hand so do some of those
tips to build your brand if you got a
short film sell it out sell for 10 20
dollars because then if you use if you
use PayPal for example and sell your
tickets now you have a database of
people that bought your tickets you know
so now you can show it best hey listen
this is my following if sometimes don't
be tricked by social media by building
your brand just because you have a
million followers or a lot of likes
doesn't mean they're gonna buy your
movie oh that's so true doesn't mean
anyone buy your book and so true doesn't
anyone comes here straining yeah so when
you have a big fall to separate the real
support from the fake yeah yeah yeah I
want to give you guys just a little
background information so I'm the kind
of guy who shows up at the party and
doesn't want to talk to anybody and it
won't tell you I'm not very sociable at
all I'm not very I'm a nice guy exactly
so I'm not one to go up and introduce
myself to people so I get it I know it's
not easy but now that I've been going to
festivals right promoting my film I got
a call back in and shaking hands and
meeting people I find that it gets
easier and you meet a lot of interesting
people so I'll give you an example I
went to the Contra film series about a
week ago
and I met this director right his name's
Carter winter and he happened to do a
short film called dead layer featuring
Michael Douglas's son I'm pretty sure
you guys know Michael Douglas's if I
didn't go to that Film Festival and I
didn't make that connection with that
director I wouldn't have known anything
about him so go to these festivals with
an open mind even if you're not
talkative and you don't like to engage
in conversation just go I'm telling you
you will learn a lot even if you go in
there just to watch it'll encourage you
and it'll build your confidence so and
that's a great point enjoy about artists
out there they're in turrets yeah yeah
speak yeah it's one of great mmm and
unless you have someone on your team you
have to go out there you have to kiss
head shake baby there's a roll good wait
hold on to it no one will promote you
like you want yourself Jeff I have
something because I probably don't go
nowhere staying in the house there we go
nowhere me I'm a homebody but how to
draw eyes that antwuan notes gonna do
this yourself you know I start blowing
Fun Festival I'm doing always after
something because I realized that this
girl gave it all I had is just not
enough I need more to bring to the table
I need to bring my value you know I
remember back in the day someone asked
me answer what your friend said table I
was like oh no that was a short you
actually that now I am the table whoa
but everybody could play and that's what
you have to do bill your brand so this
is Anson Allen
and this is Lester Green unzipped it
conversations on film courage please
you